benvenuti ad un nuovo episodio di the
sims con sabrina
siamo vestiti uguali e non voglio
vederti di forti con una ragazza senza
vestiti se la parola famiglia
ragazzi miei riprende a giocare con la
famiglia j
eravamo rimasti che io e selena eravamo
nudi che questa cosa molto strana di
nuovo nudi in calesse siamo vestiti
abbiamo caricato al partito stiamo così
nei processi
va bene allora eravamo nudi perché
avevamo fatto un bagno in piscina che
era andato finito beh meglio piscina
finito bene i nudi ovviamente hai
guardato gli interessi ci guardano e di
come mai non sono capaci a fare questa
gogna sta mangiando la torta e va bene
ma non possono vivere di torte io con
vaughn che di torti che cosa farei io
adesso cosa facciamo
prendiamo l'energia perché oggi è il
pigiama sciaudone della rivelazione è
gay
va bene ma tu intendi rivelarti o pagare
tuo amore amore preferei grossa dormendo
in un'altra stanza completamente ma
perché mi sa che si entra da qua
mamma mia nonna lei non sono capace
l'abbiamo veloce rapido tanto passerà la
notte
io mi alzo alle 5 del mattino proprio
questa cosa non è mai successa che
ciabatte ciò ragazzine come fa come fa
selena trovarmi anche solo un minimo
interessante con questa roba che ho
addosso mentre lei dorme io cosa
facciamo cosa facciamo le prepariamo la
colazione o stai andando a mangiare la
torta la mia ma andiamo a fare la
colazione prima per noi e poi per gli
altri sempre comunque la stralcio fatto
dura st torta al cioccolato che abbiamo
le lobby degli animali le ciotole per
terra se non abbiamo gli animali kakà è
la domanda era un maggiori primo maggio
di quest'anno in questo è un casino alla
kakà e poi bagno che dici
[Applauso]
mediti qualcosa addosso ti prego perché
gira così per casa spiega mi sembra un
criceto quando maglia così carina si
stanno addosso tesoro che mio dio al mi
sono innamorato mi innamoro sempre nuti
è un problema è di nuovo tanto ma c'è
una porta davanti che flirta con la
torta aspettando te ma io sto cambiando
ma sto pagando addosso
rai un bagno qui per me non è una doccia
ecco la mia doccia nella voglia una
lettiera del gatto e non puliscono e
carne si può non avere una doccia
mettiamo dire al volo a voi comprò una
doccia quindi ha soldi ma assolutamente
la mettiamo giusto al volo
ragazzi io se fosse per me prendere in
una doccia di tutto rispetto perché io
beh quell'ultima l'ultima scuse l'ultima
ora l'ultima ad esser ammette però di
aver prestato ma sono una doccia ma che
brutta ascolta ovviamente era contro
così quindi lory si può andare a darcela
bella lavata va bene ho idea se la fai
calda e sensuale
dovresti anche tu sei importante è non
ha mai offerto con me stesso nel senso
che la faccia senso ma poi voglio vedere
come la doccia sensuale scusami nattino
per curiosità
guardate signori voglio capire cosa
faccio gemiti prestare la doccia
sensuale senso che non sto capendo non
sto capendo che cosa c'è di sensuale
questa cosa avete mai visto aveva
chiesto la doccia è come questo sono
così eccolo eccolo eccolo ex sono fleur
time lei però non lo è lei dobbiamo
farla diventare noi dobbiamo far
diventare più nota
no no se l'è nando vedo cosa faccia cosa
devo fare faranno in vicinanze bloccarlo
calava qui la rivelazione ascolta
andiamo in un posto romantico davanti al
pianoforte ma in quelle sonore una
canzone nell ascolto esercitate marino
sarà bravissima sorelle immagino che sia
veramente bravi guarda io l'assalto vado
ascoltarla certo 20 quadri fianco come
penso che se prendi un bambino di tre
anni l'ho sempre più bravo però va bene
ora guarda come sono contento di
sentirmi una gioia ascolta è il momento
faccio sceglierete poi come suono al
piano con le mani e residente a
romantico offrì una rosa o fai il
baciamano battuto di abbordaggio a
direttamente senza neanche una rosa a
loro sul portierino altre scelte scelte
romantico offre la rosa prima con che
scusa lille offrirà la rosa 5 euro
ecco dove l'ho tirata fuori ma c'era un
vu cumprà fuori l'ho presa un euro si
chiama devo farci una foto figlio
smartphone al momento puoi prendere una
palla da baseball tubo testa seconda
sexy ma mio della posa sexy tra cui
conquisto le donne sappiano guarda e lei
risponde a te con anche lei cosa così si
posa sexy signore lei è decisamente più
sexy
giusto un po di sexy lite sono il cuore
in fiamme e l'attrazione attenzione
incredibile miss a sperare elisa sperare
inizia la presa molto due bogey
le scuse di cava ragazzi nei suoni
commissione la canzone della strozzatura
el'immondizia si butta cosi pari a ci
sei
ci siamo via così scale fermi
[Musica]
quello che faccia che hai fatto schifo
non ci vuol credere sempre schifato
fatto è la cosa più bella della mia vita
lei è scappata perché arancio quanto sta
andando avanti siamo fatti forse l'uno
per l'altra capisco se ne deve andare in
bagno mal di pancia sbavo come un lama
voi nostra rosa
basta più capendo niente ragazza c'era
onori impazzito è l'ormone impazzito
lorenzo mi piacciono i tuoi denti
baciano mara io colorito veramente di e
2000 rallo lorenzo lorenzo non sta
andando a un video care chiedi diventa
la fidanzata già adesso bassi dai dai
dai va al carico carico e poi sesta
fidanzati si può fare la pipì in bagno
insieme anche vai a fare la pipì in
bagno
selena vuoi fare la pipì in bagno con me
vediamo mi vuoi ammanettati con me per
caso e verde l'inizio di una relazione
selena è diventata grazie sabrina grazie
prima la società lasciali stare o
bisogna andare il passo successivo è
grave ma che mi aspetta che la festa
moretti non voglio far finire che non
voglio cercare di avere un figlio ma un
attimo no ma fino a tavola torino ma
basta ma come va misuraca ma ci siamo
piaciuti da un minuto e tu devi darci
dentro i sei sono 30 anni che non fai
niente tata nano ragazzi non posso
vedere
ecco niente ma poi aspetta perché non è
detto che perché lei rimanda quindi
sapeva di andare in bagno
puoi andare in bagno che se la fa dos ma
che schifo
pronto anche quest'anno simile cantele
eventi tanto più romantico lorenzi sera
stanno per fare i figli lo sapeva prima
cosa possiamo andare più mi son of a
vedere come te la cavi o la fico mesi
dai dentro c'è guarda che i cuoricini
questo è il momento di calo sia da
quando a perfezionare i cugini dai una
girata di cuscini un messaggio da
twister lì sotto probabilmente si no la
bella questa poltrona
va bene mangiamo ma posso cucinarmi
dell'altro per favore bonis frigorifero
per esempi di esse qualcosa prepara un
pranzo al sacco cucina cucina o facciamo
vedere la mia ragazza che so fare una
torta bianchi
no no no no a tastare incendio alla per
no no no allora no c'è un problema segni
lorenzo fai qualcosa
ora come proteggo la mia donna è morta
soffocata fai qualcosa assicurazione
abbiamo creato dei soldi vorrei quante
implicate in mezzo alla strada chi fa
qualcosa
sono fidanzata con un idiota ma cosa ho
fatto come facciamo come fa una persona
sapere fa incinta come fate sono guariti
perfetto matrioska effettua un test di
grande fama non sono i testimoni di
feriti no
dovetti compagno ma sempre molto a suo
agio
si mangia 81 ancora non lo sa io
l'omaggio dato ancora non lo sa io non
lo so me lo deve dire bene devi dirgli
l'ho mai previsto di lui proprio lui che
la grande notizia
diamo mai statico mai a suicidarsi da
qualche parte probabilmente pronto
messico vediamo avremo un bambino io non
hanno altra lingua
sei contento si contano sono proprio
contento di questo aspetto che va domani
per me va bene ragazzi nell'episodio di
oggi abbiamo portato fatto cose eccetera
eccetera staffetta c'è anche questa cosa
tra tutte che va bene un po importante
comunque sia nei prossimi episodi visto
che c'è il bambino in arrivo vediamo di
riuscire a creare la stanza del bimbo
vedere se riesce a partorire vedere cosa
devo fare nel mio tempo libero mentre le
tiene il bambino ci siamo forse bisogna
ragazzi questi schiette vi è la realtà
[Musica]